مايكل آه ، متى كانت آخر مرة
اشتريت فيها
بيتزا ببيتكوين أبدًا ، متى كانت آخر مرة
يشاهد فيها أي شخص عملة البيتكوين هذه
لإجراء معاملات تجارية تقريبًا
في الأيام الخوالي ،
هناك قصص عن أشخاص يشترون
بيتزا بعملة البيتكوين ولكننا لا
نستخدم  العملة الرقمية بعد الآن ما هي
عليه الآن هي أصل مضاربة ،
إنها قيمة مثل رقائق الكازينو
وهذا بالضبط
ما هو هذا الآن.
يمكن أن ينخفض إلى خمسة آل
ف دولار لا
عرفه تمامًا مثل gamestop ، إنه حق
ا توقف اللعبة عل
المنشطات أكبر بـ 10 مرات من games
op ، والفرق بين مخزون اللعبة و bitco
n هو أن مخ
ون اللعبة كان يعرف مجموعة من ال
هووسين والمهوسين والأشخاص الطيبين ال
ين لديهم  لا توجد خبرة في التمويل وراء
ذلك ، فلديهم مستثمرون محترفون
يعرفون أباطرة التكنولوجيا الذين يضخون
المليارات في ذلك ، لكن ما يحدث هو
أنهم يضخون المليارات
يرتفع السعر فيه ويصرفون أرباحهم ويأخذون
أرباحهم وأنت تعلم أن لديك المتعصبين مثل
صديقي دان
الذي يقنع الجميع وأنت تعرف
مستثمرين جدد
يأتون ويشترونها ويفقدون قمصانهم
ويتركونك تعلم مفلساً و  يبكي
بينما يزداد الأغنياء ثراءً ثم
يشترونه مرة أخرى بعد انخفاض السعر
ثم ينخفض مرة أخرى ، لذا فإن ال
جل العادي الشخص العادي يخ
ر بغض النظر عما يحدث هنا والأثرياء يس
مرون في الثراء.  منزل الليلة الماضية التي استخدمت فيها
النقود ، هل لدى vivik نقطة أنه حتى
وما لم تصل إلى درجة حيث
يتم استخدام البيتكوين لشراء فطيرة ليلة الجمعة ،
فليس لدينا أي شيء هنا الآن ،
يقوم البيتكوين بالعشرات من حالات الاستخدام المختلفة
من
الذهب الرقمي إلى التقاطع-  نقل الأموال من الحدود
إلى
جميع أنواع الأشياء ، وآخر
شيء ستفعله حقًا هو أن يكون جيدًا لشراء
بيتزا ، في
الواقع ، كانت أول
معاملة تجارية مع Bitcoin
مطورًا اشترى
البيتزا بعشرة آلاف  عملة البيتكوين الرملية التي
تبلغ قيمتها
500 مليون دولار وخمسة مليارات دولار
اليوم ، ولهذا السبب لا يستخدمها
الناس لشراء الأشياء
في الوقت الحالي لأنها
تقدر بمثل هذا المعدل السريع
وقد تم صنع هذه الحجج من
قبل
نسبة صغيرة جدًا من الناس  الذين يتعاملون مع
العملات المشفرة بشكل سلبي
ولكن يتم استخدامه بالفعل بنسبة سبعة في المائة
من
حركة الأموال عبر الحدود من الولايات المتحدة إلى المكسيك
تتجاوز
عملة البيتكوين التي قمنا ببيعها مؤخرًا لشركة في الفلبين لديها واحد من كل 10 بالغين في البلاد يستخدمون البيتكوين لذا عملات البيتكوين  يتم استخدامه
والمستثمرون الذين يستثمرون فيه
اليوم
لا يستثمرون فيه لأنه أمر
رائع لشراء فنجان من القهوة
اليوم يستثمرون فيه
لأنه سيعطل مدفوعات التمويل
كل هذه الصناعات وبعد 10 سنوات من
الآن سوف  تكون جيدة لشراء فنجان من
القهوة